はじめ：本気でちょっとダンスやって！
ダンサ：え？
なんかクランプっていうジャンルがあるんですよ
がんちゃんとかやってる　こう･･･
はじめ：がんちゃん てなに？
ダンサー：あの...ジェイ・ソウル・ブラザーズの･･･
分かりませんか？
はじめ：えー ちょっとここでやって
えー とし君の･･･
♪ ジャジャジャジャン　ジャジャン
はじめ：バトルパンチだっけ？
ダンサー：クランプです
はじめ：クランプでーす　どうぞ！
♪ ジャジャジャジャン　ジャジャン
<電動ドリルの音>
はじめ：アハハッ･･･
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
みなさんは ねずみという生き物をご存知でしょうか
そう英語でなんというか...
マウス
アハッハッハッハハ
ねえ 恥ずかしいから
今から 一人友達がもうすぐ僕の家に来るんですけども
そいつを驚かせようと思いまして...
あいつネズミ嫌いなんすよ
ネズミが嫌いなので 今回すごいものを買ってきました
トイザラスで買ってきました！　こちら
プルルルルルルル
じゃれマウスー
HEX BUGというリアルな動きをするものを―
つくる会社がありまして
そちらのネズミのおもちゃでございます
すごくちゃっちく見えるんですけど―
マジで動きやばいから…
HEX BUGさんのつくるやつは
マジで動きがすごいんすよ
多分本当に 本物のネズミ並みの動きを―
してくれるということを期待して買ってみました
あっきたきた　やばいよ？いくよ？
<ネズミが動く音>
は!?
あぇ!?
あああ！
めっちゃリアルじゃない？
そうでもない気がしてきちゃった
そうでもないことも　ないかもしれないとも―
言い切れないが
おれはでも 間違いなくネズミに見えてるよ
ネズミにしか見えない...完全に
こういうネズミのおもちゃがあるんですけども
今回 こちらがなんと 9個あるので
9個もあればそれっぽい動きに見えると思うんですよ
結局 集合体だと怖くなっちゃうところがあるんで
見た目的にバレちゃうんで ちょっと暗めのところで
ターゲットがきたところに―
このネズミを一斉にセットしたいと思います
わあ でもいい感じ！　いい感じだよ？
こんな感じでございます
What's the people?
あーでもよく見たら気持ち悪く
感じてきちゃったちゃちゃ
ハハハッ
正直に言いましょう　酔ってます！
ターゲットが今から入ってくるので
そこのターゲットが入ってくるところに
ネズミを9匹設置して動くようにしておいて
ターゲットがどんな反応をするのか
みんなで楽しんで見ましょうね
すごい！でも...
ポイのはわかると思います
いちいちなんか止まるのが似てない
はじめ：こういう見えない隙間からさ―
出てきたりすると怖いよね
はじめ：え！　結構怖くない？
ダンサー：めっちゃいい
はじめ：いいんじゃない？
実際動かしてみると 地味にリアルだと思うので
多分 急に入ってくるとビビると思います
ではターゲットが来るのを待ちましょう
プルルルルル
(小声)はい というわけで　ターゲットが来たので
早速仕掛けていこうと思います
はじめ：◎△＄♪×￥●＆％＃？！
通話相手：お風呂入ってるって言った？
はじめ：お風呂まだ入ってないよ？
いまね 玄関の方にいるんだよ
ちょっとまってて　今どこにいるの？
通話相手：いま玄関の前にいるよ？
はじめ：あー それかなり近いよ
痛いっ
(小声)いきます
<鍵を開ける音>
日本語字幕：すー焼きそばそー、保月静來羽、pome
思ったより違ったなぁ･･･
ペット用って書いてあるじゃん！